негайно знав прийняла налік увальня
українською shell дати їм 20 пацієнтів
прибули до аеропорту берліну на
спеціальному равликів у
airbus a310 який називають летким
вихованою вся кава будуть проходу
телевізор увальня у клініка хабар лінії
гамбурзі ульме the cable анти все
солдати були пурані не пити годину
антитерористичної операції на зводі
україни по особах з мосту травми цик
пацієнтові в їд типовим у скронь йому час
на мене - я хочу сказати коротко те і
дається право хвилі пальні пураны дня а
також про пурани дня від риму не в нас
йдуть у епоху повільно expansion столиці
він цікавився авторами
за слова ми їх і знаходиться standup
ванни huni матчі на українських ризикових
стабільною 3 виріс на двоє з них був і
про упорово нею негайно у цього хлопця
то на тріумф чим більше українських
ризикових яко що очі у або дзвонити
пеклі берліну і світло по видних пруха їм
процес заявив депутат бундестагу
gangster бартель вкорінити і бундесвер
вухом узі та науками праматір
сукні в Україні трагічні для самої
окраїни емоційна байдуже даний на
тільки через владу не світ когось
п.к.
а й через солідарність людьми там у. ми
тут робимо
c очевидний знак солідарності заданим та
бундесвер серб наука чи пари бувало
кілька ним окулярах лихарів
сам іван і вугілля дала поранених і вибрав
з них 28 це в бундесвер та правда ними
Джон і